good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm in
the office so I don't know if you seen
Sara's brilliant art assignment video
the case for Kanye West but after
watching it I've been listening more
carefully to Kanye's music and there's a
lyric in the song power that's really
stuck with me
it goes they say I was the abomination
of Obama's nation well that's a pretty
bad way to start a conversation
I think the grammatical ambiguity of
that's a pretty bad way to start a
conversation is important here side note
don't tell me Kanye didn't mean any of
this because he's not that smart or
whatever one authorial intent doesn't
matter and to Kanye is that smart I mean
sometimes he's an offensive buffoon but
so are a lot of smart people but right
so saying you're the abomination of
Obama's nation is indeed a pretty bad
way to start a conversation right
because you're calling someone a name
you're also using cleverness to make
yourself seem correct but they say I was
the abomination of Obama's nation is
also a pretty bad way to start a
conversation I mean first off you're
using the nonspecific day as a way of
constructing a false us versus them
dichotomy
also most Kanye haters weren't actually
calling him the abomination of Obama's
nation they were criticizing other
things about him and his work but then
Kanye simplified and repackaged those
arguments in a way that made them seem
ridiculous you see all these bad ways of
starting conversations a lot in
contemporary discourse think of all the
gotcha moments in the 24 hour political
news cycle and the use of diminutive x'
and name-calling I mean from Canadian
cruise to crooked Hillary to lie and
Donald to Barry Obama they all undermine
and demean people in a way that's like a
little too vague to defend yourself
against there's the rhetorical questions
the certainty of one's own opinion wit
masquerading as accuracy the sharing of
one study you read about once instead of
doing the research to learn with the
bulk of evidence currently points to the
presumption that those who disagree with
you are merely wrong the list goes on
and on my favorite at the moment is
where you accuse a voice you don't like
of being shrill or shouty or aggressive
even when it isn't which is a tactic so
meta that even Kanye couldn't parse it I
do this too by the way like the other
day I said on Twitter that 40% of US gun
sales involved no background checks
which turns out to be a totally
unsupported statistic but by the time I
did the relevant research the tweet was
already out there furthering the
ceaseless spread of misinformation so I
don't get a pass on this one
but research shows that rude aggressive
and inaccurate comments don't just lower
the overall quality of conversation they
also make people feel more
and afraid and while I think Kong is
right about all these bad ways of
starting conversations their effective
ways to start conversations because we
all feel compelled to respond like
hostility generally gets answered with
hostility and when the outrage button
gets pressed inside of us we want to
share and reply and do all the other
things that the architecture of social
media currently values so trolling is
poisonous but it works and that's why
the front page of most YouTube comments
sections doesn't contain the most
interesting or generous or nuanced
comments but instead the most
controversial ones and I know those
controversial comments get replies but I
don't think they change anyone's mind
like screaming at each other is a bad
way of listening but I think it's also a
bad way of getting heard now I realize
that's easy for me to say since I
already have a platform but I truly
don't think anyone has ever changed
their mind because they were called an
idiot Hank I really loved your video
last week about race and racism in the
United States but the comments section
was a disaster until you made a Hank's
Channel video asking people to simply
reply with a plus sign to comments they
agreed with that immediately tricked the
youtube comment algorithm into valuing
generous and thoughtful comments which
in turn made commenting far more civil
and productive it's a small thing and it
wasn't perfect but it made a real change
in that online conversation and I know
I'll be using the plus sign reply from
here on out there advisors if you have
other suggestions for how we might
improve the quality of conversations
both here and in the wider world I'll be
in comments doing my best to listen Hank
I'll see you on Friday